alright let's see here carry the one and
we do oh oh oh hi sorry just caught me
finishing up my taxes here yeah it's up
the end of the fiscal year a lot of
video game companies are rushing out to
get as many games as they possibly can
out by the end of March to beef up that
old bottom line in fact there's so many
video games coming out this week I
didn't even have time to put together
any kind of contrived obviously fake
introduction for this week's video so
let's let's just get to the games right
away cliffy B may be gone but Gears of
War trudges on Gears of War judgement
available March 19 for Xbox 360 is the
first entry in the mega-popular
third-person shooter series to be
developed by people can fly the creators
of bulletstorm this new entry is a
prequel that gives you a new perspective
on the series storyline if you'd rather
kill zombies than locusts activision has
you covered with walking dead survival
instinct for playstation 3 360 and wii u
note that this is not the acclaimed
adventure game that was Wired's game of
the year in 2012 this is a totally
different first person shooter take on
the popular TV show Activision hasn't
let anyone play it yet so it's
impossible to say if you should buy it
on March 19 I would say wait but walking
dead isn't the only Wii U game this week
Nintendo might have delayed everything
else but it's still bringing out lego
city undercover on march 18 steven
totilo at Kotaku played through it and
said it's like a grand theft auto four
kids fun clever open world but maybe a
little too hand holdy and easy for
adults on March 19 Capcom is delivering
monster hunter 3 ultimate for both the
wii u and nintendo 3ds you can hunt down
giant creatures online with your friends
on Wii U or locally with the 3ds there's
also cross play so if you've got 3ds and
Wii U's in the same room you can all
team up and of course you can transfer
your saved game data
between the two systems and finally
Nintendo is releasing two new 3ds games
on Sunday March 24 pokemon mystery
dungeon that unlikely combination of
dungeon hacking and Pocket Monsters is
back with gates to infinity and Mario's
forever tormented brother Luigi finally
gets his own starring role again in
luigi's mansion dark moon explore a
series of haunted houses tracking down
ghosts and sucking them up into your
vacuum and I cannot leave you this week
without mentioning the release of
ridiculous fishing for iPhone and iPad
from the amazing indie developers who
brought you games like super crate box
and spell tower it is a very fun very
creative fishing game and it only costs
299 so if you only spend three dollars
on video gaming this week spend it on
ridiculous fishing that's it for this
week we'll see you next time on game
life